[BOLLING] Some guy came up to me and said,
"I saw you on ‘Fox & Friends’ this morning.
Is Gretchen as cute in person as she is on
TV?"
[KILMEADE] And what did you answer?
[BOLLING] Gorgeous, gorgeous! Look at her
today. Beautiful dress. You look wonderful.
[BOLLING] Gretchen, you look wonderful.
[BOLLING] Gretchen, very, very beautiful dress
there. Great color.
[BOLLING] In summary, Gretchen's beautiful!
[JOHNSON] Beautiful. You look beautiful. Thank
you.
[CARLSON] Well, you look fabulous too!
[KILMEADE] Brian, can you tell Gretchen she
is definitely winning today? She looks amazing.
[CARLSON] Wow.
[KILMEADE] And no, it’s not because ‘Fox
& Friends’ is too hot.
But Gretchen is really too hot. Blame her!
[BRIGGS] and skirts—Gretchen, I guess what you're wearing right now
—the skirt—might cause some problems.
[CARLSON] It would not be advisable for the
pat down.
[DOOCY] Gretchen is gonna ride the mechanical
bull, live from our snowy plaza.
[CARLSON] And a lot of viewers are concerned
that I'm gonna have the skirt on when I do it.
[KILMEADE] I'm not sure, but 'concerned'—that's
an interesting word.
[DOOCY] In the next two minutes, will Laura
Ingraham be able to change outfits, because
she has come to the studio dressed identically
to Gretchen. What are you thinking?!
[CARLSON] All women should be reading bra stories,
but then again, some men are experts at this.
[KILMEADE] You learn that at Broadcasting
Nine?
[DOOCY] Bra-casting
[KILMEADE] Yeah, bra stories—defer to the
babe.
[KILMEADE] Doesn't waxing hurt?
[DOOCY] It does. [CARLSON] He looks at me for that!
[DOOCY] We'll try that on an upcoming episode
of 'Fox & Friends.'
[KILMEADE] Do you like a woman masseuse or
a male masseuse? Just so I know.
[DOOCY] Not on TV.
[INGRAHAM] I am not gonna answer that. I am
not—
[CARLSON] You know what, Laura—now you know
what I go through, okay?
[CARLSON] Would you like to correct yourself on that other talking point,
about men being dominant?
[KILMEADE] Oh, we don't have any time. I wish
we did. We're running over.
[CARLSON] Okay, 'cause HR's on the phone because
you called me a skirt.
[KILMEADE] Yeah, I apologize. I gotta read
that manual again.
[CARLSON] I'll bring it to your office right
after the show.
[KILMEADE] It was the only sexist person that
came on here and made you laugh, alright?
[CARLSON] Other than sitting next to you every
day.
[KILMEADE] Right! That's true. I'm not—but
I'm having fun with it.
[CARLSON] You're a jest sexist.
[KILMEADE] Yes, I jest that I'm sexist.
[DOOCY] Jest! Just in time.
[CARLSON] I think we should read the headlines.
[KILMEADE] I think it's just you.
[CARLSON] Okay.